I feel comfortable so few cameras really
I know we have one here one here one
here you've gotta be able to do the
having them so they give you that NFL
thing where you like swoop around
matrix-style
you now have them on the red carpet to
do I dress it like at 360 dresses as
they should I put your hand in so you
can see the nails no yeah the thing it
is and there's a tweet cam I've seen
also it just takes a picture and then it
tweets for you no you go under the
camera and you show them what you're
eating yeah oh this is like the
excitement of seeing them like make a
typo and then go back and delete it it's
like Oh celebrities make mistakes I'm
allergic to the internet all right
well I do I'm not very and I check it
here and there yeah um but she's always
on Twitter no I'm at she's I'm really no
look at her she's like she's like her
I'm like oh no it's between no I really
am addicted to Instagram not me but to
and Twitter yeah I do it here and there
well what about YouTube I mean I know
you guys we're just in this movie called
the internship that you shot at Google
do is have any favorite YouTube videos
at all do you watch YouTube um I do use
YouTube a lot a lot for music sometimes
if I don't have the album if I want to
know if I like all the songs then I
don't check it out on YouTube I like a
lot of the little babies that laugh out
loud and cry those are really funny I'm
a big fan of a video called kid gets hit
in the head with a basketball if you
haven't seen that it's bad for you yes
but I think it's probably the great it's
like it's like it's like the Mozart of
YouTube it's this perfect it's just
perfect only four seconds that's like
maybe 14 seconds okay it's it's perfect
I just know about how these people
happen to always be in the right place
at the right time I've never been in a
place that something has happened that I
filmed and been able to post I feel like
people do that all the time now I'll go
to a concert and we're actually watching
like the live concert there and
everyone's watching it through their
phone I'm like they're right there just
watch it so I feel like everyone always
has their phone and I guess catches it
yeah I was actually so bad that it went
to Bon Jovi concert and I brought my
iPad
oh so cuz well then you had it's even
better for you to I'm like holding out
my iPad
holding up an iPhone you're making
YouTube video I am that person
now do you use find it all I have it
it's a good yes I know that's the thing
I've heard of it's pretty fun let me
tell you what if you guys seen this
little game by Matt as my dad I mean
this probably is I'll just hear
someone's father looks a lot like my dad
yes
who wants to go first yes oh good okay I
keep going you sure it's turned on
frankly I'm most concerned about his
nose that doesn't seem normal
okay I took a bunch of pre-med classes
did you really yeah okay do you guys
ever have any crazy internships I have
not but I would like to get one at
Google because when we were filming
there I'm like this is the best
workplace ever it's Disneyland for
adults yeah everything the games bowling
cards bullying yeah there's like a
bowling alley volleyball courts with by
generating currents he's really killing
Mary rubberband situation that seems
very challenging really not a problem
you are a professional
well oh there's a toilet in his stomach
oh I feel like somebody should be
monitoring this guy I mean it might be
the coffee okay how about you try no
come on right there
look at him oh my gosh I think you got
it so they've made some updates there's
a self out yes that's okay you got
it
well done very so how much fun was it
working on the show
movie rather not a show I had such an
amazing time I'd never worked with
anyone in the film had never been to
Atlanta I'd never really taken the dance
lessons that I had to take for my
character so everything was very new how
were her dancing skills I don't want to
say perfect because they were better
than wow yeah I mean I'm immaculate as
divinely inspired I have a whole new
respect for strippers this is the
hardest workout that I've ever had to do
and I'm athletic and stuff but yeah and
it was the best shape I was ever in and
I'm gonna continue to take pole dancing
lessons for sure for a workout but yeah
you're using thank you guys for playing
operation with me thank you I was the
best yeah I'm not sure how the rest of
your cast mates are doing but I will
keep you guys posted as this day
progresses
well yeah anything else that you might
want to tell one of these cameras about
the movie and the internet anything hey
guys
CJ's or the internship on June 7th well
thank you guys thank you